I was trying to remember last night I
was thinking about things and I was like
what was that story Benji was telling us
it was about it a date he had Benji come
in and should I get him in here or not
yeah let's try all right
don't blame me if this goes wrong it'll
be my fault okay I bet
what's going on with dating so I was on
a date it was actually a girl I met in
person which was a weird thing she
flirted with me which has only happened
one other time in my life were you where
were you I was at Petco a girl was
holding a cat toy and I it was a cute
girl and I said oh you are you getting
that so your cat chases you and then she
waved it in my face which goes I'm I
want you to chase me oh wow only one
other time in my life have I had an
experience where a girl flirted with me
well like in person that a stranger at
this wait she said I want you to chase
me did you say listen I'm too heavy to
change it was like a sitcom I stammered
I forgot like my purchase at the counter
this was a really good-looking girl you
say cute girl right cute girl like what
ten or nine or seven what is she a cute
seven Wow
yeah but at 70 pounds over cute seven is
a nine cuz you're 70 pounds over yeah
right I was nervous I walked to the
corner and I was like I should go talk
to her so I wouldn't talk to her I asked
her out and she kind of hesitated like
she was gonna say no that she said sure
uh-huh
so then I I called her and we went out
the next night oh wow yeah how old how
old is she yeah no no how old are you
when I say how old would I mean I know
you so who do you think I'm talking
about I don't know I never you know what
I never asked her that but would you say
she was in her 20s or 30s at least
thirty she could have been 40 I don't I
don't know for trying so we went out and
it actually was not going great it was a
stifled conversation right and then she
started talking about that douche bag in
office that that's what that was her
words and I said well I gotta be honest
I that douche bag
right in a way it broke the bubble and
we started talking a little looser but
she was she just looked at me like I
really liked you I thought you were a
good person I don't understand this
right but that's happened on several
dates actually you
KYNA cock-blocked yourself look if you
live in New York most people are pretty
liberal here and when you say I voted
for Trump that's like saying you have an
STD in New York you know what that does
narrow the feet it does should put up
with that